hi there this is steve this is day four
yesterday was day three i made a mistake
on the title of my video
um what did i do today well i started
out by doing a little bit of advanced
korean
uh which i bought some years ago because
my friend ross king of university of
british columbia puts it out
uh i didn't do much with it but now i
found it online so i imported it into
link and i studied it in lincoln i have
not finished this book i've gone through
all the lessons uh on link
then
uh oh yeah and then because i
kind of hurt my rotator cuff and i don't
want to get i don't want to ruin it for
the hockey tournament on the 20th of
september you know 70 and over bc senior
games
so i didn't play golf my wife went to
play golf and i
there was this meetup cantonese speakers
meet up walk the seawall so i went down
there but um there's only two other
people and they insisted on speaking
english so i left
but on my way there and on my way back
i was listening to
this
which is
sort of all the basic patterns of korean
lots and lots and lots of examples of
different patterns so i like listening
to this in the car because they're just
running through all those patterns i
come back and i might read through a
little bit
and then i started doing something
quite interesting because
there's always a few words there that
i'd like to incorporate into my
vocabulary so i started actually uh
transcribing and actually dictating so
i'm reading this text i read it out i'm
dictating it into
my ipad because i have a korean keypad
on my ipad and if it's set to korean the
dictation
software on there will dictate into
korea so i did that for a while and then
i got tired of that
and then i went to this other book i
thought well if i can do it for these
then i'll do it for this other book
which is um
you know
kyojon param
you know it's
apparently standard pronunciation i
bought it's a book about in japan quite
a while ago
it consists of uh basically um
you know korean on one side and japanese
on the other
but i'm not a fan of reading you know
bilingual texts because normally there's
only a small percentage of words that i
need and i don't want to have to go
through the other side to find those
words
and while reading in saying japanese
which i can do comfortably or in english
makes it easier for me to read the
korean
but actually it spoils the interest so
i'm not a big fan of these parallel
texts and so what i did was and
successfully i
therefore dictated reading and dictated
occasionally i go in and correct it
typing in korean
and then i um
uploaded that
from my ipad i put it into
google documents it shows up on my
computer on my computer i copy the
google documents i import it into link
and then i study it on link and later on
i will get the
audio cd
and load up the audio for that if i feel
like doing so but
i think all of this is interesting
because it's different ways of dealing
with the language
you know studying different texts doing
different tasks i think i stress this
all the time repetition and novelty keep
it interesting change things around so
you don't lose interest it's good for
the brain it keeps you motivated helps
you notice things
and make sure that you put the time into
the task so there you have it keep the
questions coming um
i'm not going to answer the questions i
might just answer the questions directly
on the youtube page rather than taking
up video time to answer the questions
thanks for listening and
keep going on your 90 day challenge bye
for now